the College Board is facing criticism
over claims that it changed its new AP
class on African-American studies
because of political pressure last month
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis threatened
to ban the class because it included
topics like the black lives matter
movement reparations and black feminist
thought State officials cited an early
draft of the curriculum the College
Board released the official curriculum
yesterday the black lives matter
movement and reparations are now listed
as optional project topics and according
to the New York Times several
trailblazing Black authors were removed
including Bell hooks who wrote about
race and feminism now yesterday on CBS
mornings we asked the College Board they
were here CEO David Coleman how they
created the revised curriculum
we at the College Board don't really
look to the statements of politicians
but we do look to the record of History
so when we revised the course there were
only two things we went to we went to
what brand new described which is
feedback from teachers and students as
well as 300 professors who have been
involved in building the course and we
went back to principals that have guided
AP for a long time and served us well
uh tanahasi coach joins us at the table
you know him of course the best-selling
author between the world and me the
water dancer and
and were and we were eight years in
power remember that too he is also a
professor at Howard University always
good to have you in the studio ta-nehisi
coats so what concerns you most about
the revisions that you're hearing well
really what concerns me is the climate
around the revisions
um I'm certainly not uh uh a person with
qualifications to design a curriculum
for AP even AP for African-American
studies I think the board should be free
to do their work and do their pilot
programs and go through the process and
not be influenced not just by my
thoughts but by the thoughts of
Governors legislatures who are passing
laws uh who apparently just want a
curriculum that makes people feel
comfortable and feel good about
themselves now the College Board told us
yesterday this was not about politics
the updates they say were based on two
factors comments from over 300
professors and returning to the
principles of AP what do you make of
that if that's what they say that's what
they say by the way we should also point
out that they they their response to the
New York Times article is pretty
aggressive they call it a gross misrep
presentation
they they say it is Rife with
inaccuracies and they claim to have time
stamped evidence showing that they made
these changes before Florida said
anything publicly criticizing the course
right that's their position on this uh
but I think we're having a larger
discussion here about how we should uh
talk about race in this country uh both
in history both in the present and then
in the future because the Future Has
political ramifications
um what are your takeaways for that
larger conversation that we're having
now I think you ought to embrace
discomfort
um I think there is a mistaken belief
that somehow the study of
African-American history and American
history at large is comfortable for
African Americans
um it's not it's hard to watch video of
Rodney King it's hard to look at the
picture of Emmett Till It's hard to
watch a bloody Sunday this is not you
know activities that we enjoy doing and
so and how about Tyree Nichols right now
in the news right now and so when you
have like laws like this this uh stop
woke law that prohibits any sort of uh
curriculum or training that makes uh
people feel bad or feel uncomfortable
this is deeply antithetical to the
project of Education period And I just
think that needs to get across it's
important to remind people this AP
course is an elective it's your choice
but it's forcing you to take it and it
is a college level class college is
different than high school right but we
allow gifted students who want to to
learn from it right to point to Tony's
Point how should race be taught in
classrooms around America in your
opinion yeah well um I don't think I'm
qualified to say that first of all on
that level you know I just don't you
know I got to stay in my Lane in terms
of that but again I do have to go back
to what I said
um the idea that it should merely be
comfortable that should make you feel
good about yourself that it should make
you feel good about your country it
should make you just feel good about
your world as opposed to being
enlightened which is a very very
different thing again I just think
that's totally totally antithetical I
teach writing down at Howard University
um I teach writers that did not think my
students were human beings I teach
writers with racist sexist Etc because
they have something to say and something
to teach that can actually be used that
my students should know even if they
disagree with them how will you know
what you disagree with if you haven't
read it yeah I mean I think about the
Tulsa the riots in Tulsa I didn't even
know that story until I was an adult I
was never taught that story I mean and
it seems like we should be no we should
know we should know those kinds of we
should know that about our history black
and white it only seems to be targeted
politically or in large part when it
comes to African-American studies am I
reading that wrong well I think that's a
large part of it you know I have to be
honest this has expanded to LGBT you
know studies uh and I think uh in
general any sort of narrative that makes
a certain group of Americans and I would
say a minority of Americans are
uncomfortable um I think that's where
you're going to have yeah the Republican
to the to the extent of the Republican
criticism of a course like this is
rooted in something it's rooted in not
liking identity politics and therefore
also not liking any discipline that
drills down on identity that's
African-American studies that's queer
studies that's gender studies I guess
they would want them all subsumed under
the header of just American history or
American studies yeah I mean but
American is in in and of itself an
identity you know and the reason why we
have all these other things you know uh
African-American studies quiz studies
you know women's studies Etc is actually
to analyze and figure out what that
thing is what is you know what is that's
a great Point yeah who are we what is
our story who's at the center of and the
reality is history makes us
uncomfortable and when we are in a space
of uncomfortability in a classroom it
leads people to be vulnerable and say
things that open other people's minds
you know I I think that's exactly right
um I think you don't go into the gym and
tell your trainer hey I want to feel
like I'm eating strawberry shortcake I
mean that that is the nature of getting
better and improving yourself it is
deeply deeply uncomfortable and
sometimes it hurts but now you've got at
least 25 other states that are
considering the legislation that would
limit you know how race and racism is
taught in schools what's the danger of
that for students um the danger is uh
producing a generation of people who are
deeply uninformed about the country that
they live in is their role for
celebration and patriotism within that I
do I do I do I mean I I but I think it
has to be earned you know what I mean
you don't get to you know uh celebrate
on the one hand you know all of the good
things and then ignore all the bad
things on the other hand like I don't
think that's actually a true and real
grounded a sense of patriotism at all
Tennessee coach thank you very much
always a pleasure to have you thanks
guys thank you